it's party time in chesza not eco pretty
ohne every mini-note DeRosa meaning pink
night is one of Italy's biggest beach
festivals revelers gather all along the
adriatic coast between católica and
camacho visitors from all over europe as
well as italy there is some many young
people here and everybody's just
enjoying all this belmar great beach
great people lots of music lots of fun
great evenings litigated to laugh summer
good weather have a really fantastic
rimini so it's really great ones naughty
Rosa incorporates hundreds of parties
concerts and other events the bars and
restaurants along the coast offer a
themed pink food and drink two million
tourists were expected in the region
this time around Rhonda said that where
the masses are the money rolls in that's
how it always is this year the festival
motto was Italian passion it's also the
title of an exhibition at remedies City
Museum that focuses on one of Italy's
famous love stories in the 13th century
the young but already married Francesca
to Remini fell in love with her
brother-in-law Paolo her husband took
revenge and killed them both
Dante Alighieri featured the illicit
lovers in his Divine Comedy in questo
say so p the exhibition reflects the
theme of this year's notre rosa soon
since la passion is a topic that goes
along well with the famous story of
Paolo and Francesca who were from Remini
where Papa it's a passion reflected by
people here the note de Rosa's main
venue is remedy
the city first opened its bathing beach
in 1843 it became an exclusive resort
mass tourism began in the 1960s and
continued growing through to the late
90s thanks to package tours but the
city's popularity has waned since
particularly among Italians noted Rosa
was launched in response in 2006 and
took off hotels are regularly booked out
and since 2008 the number of visitors
has doubled in superior ricola records
you have to keep telling you stories to
present our region's attractions
constantly we won the tourists to return
they encounter our identity here our
roots our culture which we combine with
something new each year the summer fest
features the giants of Italian pop music
the highlight of this year's concert
series rock singer aliza about 50,000
people attended the free of charge
performance
when you play for free it's I think it's
awesome that you get it you get a very
mixed crowd and um you know there's like
people walking by or it's that there's a
different atmosphere it's not like your
own audience so it's like conquering
someone you don't know you have to like
find a way to communicate another
highlight of the summer festival is the
10 minute long fireworks display at
midnight on Friday it's staged at 20
different locations along the coast
the last beach was the best place to see
all the fireworks they were just too
beautiful Bella first a real success a
great initiative my compliments the
naughty Rosa the perfect event for party
lovers and great publicity for the
entire region